[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
hello everybody how you doing this is
Lord pdtv here to give you all another
iron Lords podcast first look at another
video
um or I should say another game about uh
something that I enjoyed playing
actually way more than I thought I
wanted I was going to
um so the game is called steam World
build now uh there's multiple different
versions of steam World
um but this specific one is basically
you are in charge of building a town
with a mine and you end up sending your
people into that mine to be able to
bring up resources and find artifacts
and and things like that uh so you can
I'm hoping eventually to to fly off the
world now we were given this key um from
uh Thunder fall I think it's wonderful
yes wonderful
um publishing thunderfield development
whatever you want to uh call it the
developer or the publisher uh they're
you know one in the same now um it is
right now a demo there is the one on
Steam if you want to go pick that one up
uh and you don't want to play it and see
how it goes uh it took me about an hour
to go through the whole entire uh demo
process and it gave you a real great
base of uh what you're starting to do so
um you are a essentially
City builder in charge of a town you end
up building portions of this town out uh
and then once you end up building parts
of the Town out uh you upgrade it to you
know have Engineers be brought into this
town once you have these Engineers built
up you can end up building out a mind
Silo once you build out that mind Silo
you can then go into this underground
type view of the Mind Silo which makes
you kind of go through and clear out the
Mind grab things out of their like get
different supplies things like that and
then end up coming back to the top side
for the you know for your world to do
other things to build let's say sheet
metal facilities or or other things like
that and that's the sheet metal
facilities then end up allowing you to
build bridges in in the in the mind so
there's other there's so so many layers
in different aspects of the game which I
thought was very very cool it was very
easy to pick up if you're ever used any
other city builders like City skylines
live prison Architects like those types
of games
um you have all of those
um types of games you're kind of related
to and used to now the game
um
the graphics on it were pretty good uh
they're pretty solid
um I really enjoyed the whole steampunk
look and feel of everything I thought
that the
the whole train thought process and
aspect of it was pretty cool so there
was lots of really really cool little
things about the game that I think
everyone will really really enjoy
playing and seeing so
um why don't you go ahead and I'm gonna
let the video play for a little bit uh
so you all can see it um once again my
name is Laura pdtv I myself am on
YouTube and twitch uh and I play on
Twitter until Monday through Friday so
you can go check it out there um and you
know check out the iron Lords podcast
every single Sunday and uh check out
um warzagaming.net for all of our gaming
news when we are available there
um so yeah I would definitely uh check
out the game check out that demo build
see if you like it and uh be ready for
for the launch it's it's it's not been
stated yet but um it's gonna be coming
out soon so I would definitely think you
guys should pick it up and play it so
thanks again everyone have a fantastic
week bye everybody
[Music]
um
buyers duology game
a place to remind us to rest to resupply
a electric quarters the more miners get
support
let's see at least nine
Big Tool
all right
interesting
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all that can do
okay
oh look at that they're cleaning that
area up now
oh
dirty water
[Music]
they can go through dirt but not
Sandstone it's very interesting
foreign
Bridges this is interesting
oh look at this they're putting up
handrails
that's pretty awesome
to go to the city
all right uh ticket prices are going to
the city upgrade with more workers
Engineers or fulfilling and things
trip
we got so we're going through this real
quick
um
foreign
down make all those guys happy
[Music]
animals structures bark junk Gardens
where's the tools option
oh we started doing Sandstone now
we got tools huh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what the deal is is that you're
essentially like building uh
a town but it's like a steampunk type
down so like everybody's like a robot
so what ends up happening is you build a
town you get your people
um throughout the whole entire town your
workers your engineers so on and so
forth
and
um
you kind of go into your mind and you do
your thing and
trying to go through it
it's just kind of cool
I really like think this is pretty cool
how they ended up doing this especially
a lot cooler than I thought it was gonna
be
okay
and like right now since we are
underground like it's possible to have
to take evens and stuff which is kind of
cool
oh look another iron vein
[Music]
but yeah it's really really cool
two little amount of prospector
for our prospector
this is our mechanics quarter this is
our prospector's quarters
baseball
what is this
service inhabitants
but I will say this like this game
it's definitely very very different the
way it like it ends up playing and
operates and everything and it's kind of
that's what I think makes it different
than other games that I've played before
because I've played a bunch of like
types of games like this but never
never liked this before
and right now I'm just like digging out
everything and anything and I don't even
care anymore
like I want to see what this lever goes
so we're gonna build a bridge over here
but that's just gonna shock this area
here
and open this door
this exercise in this rocket part what
what's a rocket fart
like as you can tell like I am like
Excavating everything
everything everything
when stuff like that happens I think
like something like fell down or worked
apart and I'm just like cringing I'm
like no
[Music]